so why are you saying earlier and was
that and like Joanne I don't think that
kind of rules seriously mmm-hmm
what no I have to stain for those
characters in there
cartoonish psychology but she doesn't
miss Maestas apparent me don't get
jealous not attractive quality she dives
headfirst into a character's and
abilities but I don't that's why you
admire what she does yeah
you know I think that when you watch her
in a movie like the one we saw tonight
there is there is no distance there
that's normally so culture right yeah
agreed what's wrong with my acting
nothing
do I need to do do you make you admire
me do I think what huh point to
classical know it like you're here to
talk to me so start talking hmm I don't
know you you can't be as accomplished as
you are and as well-rounded as an
actress as you are and still expect to
hold on to the privileges of youth it
just doesn't work like that
oh so I'm allowed to not be old as long
as I don't want to be young is that it
yeah I don't know I guess so yes totally
well put